welcome back to CBS this morning here
are three things you should know this
morning Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein is expected to leave the
Justice Department next month after the
confirmation of Attorney General William
Barr now this announcement follows the
60 Minutes interview with former acting
director of the FBI that's Andrew McCabe
McCabe said that Rosen's died offered to
wear a wire to record President Trump in
the White House and did raise the issue
of using the 25th amendment to remove
him from office
the DOJ official disputed the idea that
Rosen Stein's departure has anything at
all to do with that sixty minutes
interview tourists visiting the Grand
Canyon's museum collections building
have been exposed to radiation for years
the Arizona Republic reports a safety
manager for the park says the exposure
came from uranium rocks stored in
buckets the containers could have
exposed adults to 400 times the health
limit and for children up to 4,000 times
what is considered safe rocks have been
removed and an investigation is underway
the park says there is no danger to the
public
a new study finds screen time for kids
under two has more than doubled the
study published in the journal JAMA
Pediatrics found daily screen time went
from just under one and a half hours in
1997 to an average of three hours in
2014 television accounted for over two
and a half hours the American Academy of
Pediatrics recommends that children
under the age of two avoid all digital
media together this is one of the most
important things I remember look it's
different for every parent we certainly
need the iPad babysitter on a plane
sometimes damnit but we are not under
the age of two it's a no no no no books
toys just give them what I was given a
box of wooden blocks and a tub of paste
they'll be fine
we're your parents manage you frequently
and when all else fails there's key
rings that's very like jangling keys